that was sin city a dame to kill for
right around the corner figure as you
review the original cuz it's cool if I
wanted to be thematic about I should
probably film it like this that looks
kind of boring so I won't Sin City
so Sin City came out in 2005 I believe
it was and honestly I believe it changed
everything about graphic novel movies I
don't mean like you know it paid homage
to it and it kind of Illustrated what
the graphic novel was like no I'm saying
the pages were on the screen Sin City
has a black and white stylistic look but
you know the Bloods all red and
sometimes one color on the character
will shine and everything else is black
and white kind of like this I know it's
kind of cool right if I were in Sin City
this is probably how I would look now
I'm filming this like that because that
looks pretty sharp I really liked it I'm
not even going to call this a movie I'm
not going to call it a graphic novel
movie I will say it is a motion graphic
novel on the big screen or small screen
now that it's not on blu-ray this is a
graphic novel from how the characters
talk to the shots and execution it is
Frank Miller's graphic novel and now
you're watching it happen
I believe the fact that Sin City exists
in the world is the reason Neil Gaiman
is up for the possibility of having a
Sandman movie out there I think you
watch Sin City and he's like alright
well I mean if they can make it that
accurate sure let's do Sandman but
getting right into it Sin City is the
story actually it's three different
stories combined into one yet the story
of hardigan played by Bruce Willis he
saves this little girl from being raped
and now she grows up and his yellow
bastards coming after her he's you know
protecting her and then you have Marv
Marv is this truly hard Street guy
played by Mickey Rourke my favorite
character in the entire movie I thought
it was gonna be hard again I thought it
was gonna be Bruce Willis all like oh
he's gonna kick ass and he does kick ass
but dude Marv Marv did not save his
beloved hooker who gave him one night of
bliss no she died but he was set up to
take the fall for it now he is on a
revenge spree then you have Dwight
played by Clive Owen Dwight's dating
Brittany Murphy and Benicio del Toro
plays her boyfriend Dwight's also her
boyfriend also Britney Murphy's
boyfriends kind of out of his mind so
twice like I'll take care of it then
this big turf war is gonna happen
between these chicks and it gets kind of
crazy that's right one guy protecting a
little girl another guy out for revenge
for a girl who got murdered and another
guy protecting his girlfriend and then
fighting alongside a bunch of girls this
movie has one strong big unifying factor
and that is dames is very Tarantino ish
or Robert Rodriguez ish and I
Tarantino was a guest director which
probably means Robert Rodriguez was like
- Tarantino come on set it's pretty cool
you know I'll let you direct a shot come
on and it's a really exciting stylistic
very unique movie it even has the lingo
the graphic novel has everyone talks
like a really exaggerated Jimmy
Stewart's abusive older brother and [ __ ]
we're all like okay nothing like a boot
in the rear and a bum ticker a boot in
the rear and a place called Times Square
which I would say is a negative and I do
have to touch on the fact that sometimes
the acting in this movie you're like
it's not good acting is it either it's
bad acting or they're paying homage by
exaggerating the dialogue some people
will find it as a negative sometimes you
do see it as a negative but you can't
discredit the fact that the movie is
paying respect to the source material
sometimes this movie's a little strange
sometimes the scene you're like does it
make sense that the head is talking and
the head is severed and the dudes dead
yeah it's happening inside - why it's
mine doesn't change the fact that it's
gonna put some people off and they're
not gonna understand the style then the
[ __ ] goes down sometimes the people get
shot it's like a white splatter
sometimes it's a yellow splatter
sometimes it's a red splatter what's
different colors and sometimes it's
silhouetted all the time it's just like
how it is in the graphic novel I like
that I can't really compare this movie
to another movie hopefully I can compare
it to sin city a dame to kill for if I
can that would suck would really suck
this movies absurdly violent you watch
it you're like alright so this is why
some critics hated the [ __ ] out of this
movie so like violence it's bad it makes
it feel weird I didn't know how to
handle environment violence is in movies
a lot if you like those violent ish
Robert Rodriguez Tarantino movies and
you like the writings of Frank Miller I
don't even know why I'm doing this
review because you've already seen the
movie because you like that [ __ ] I love
the scene where Rosario Dawson's
character calls Clive Owens character
Lancelot and I was like I'm actually no
he's King Arthur's eyes maybe laughs so
what's this movie violent yes is it
always cohesive not always but is it
cool yes entertaining yes cool
characters yeah three badass main
characters absolutely can you compare it
to a lot of other movies not really it's
one of those movies were you compared to
about five other movies to describe this
one movie and revealing an older movie
that I really loved when it came out now
I review movies and I watch it again I
always go into him scared I'm like oh is
it gonna hold the test of time I don't
know but honestly this is such a cool
moving is broken up into three different
stories so if you just want to watch
one story nearly all right I'll put it
off till tomorrow now you'll be
completely entertained by the one story
or you can watch all three and just have
this two hour 20 minute fest of great
sense that he has more nut shots than an
all Johnny Cage combat fest and is
definitely worth buying on blu-ray
naysayers to that we'll probably have
one thing to say they're like no is this
kind of I don't know it was like it was
a comic book yeah almost time weird
so Sin City have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more